[Musik]
Handy Alarm und damit ganz schnell rein
in das Gespräch mit Peter Tschentscher
direkt am Kanzleramt denn Paul
ronsheimer empfängt live Infos aus den
Parteigremien jetzt das politische
Berlin das läuft sich jetzt richtig warm
jetzt haben die Gremiensitzung begonnen
bei der SPD und vor allen Dingen bei der
CDU und von dort hast du auf dein Handy
Infos bekommen sag uns welche Kai das
sind vielleicht die spannendsten
Gremiensitzung die ist seit 4 Jahren
gegeben hat hier entscheidet sich was in
Deutschland passieren wird am Ende und
gerade eben hat sich Armin Laschet der
Kanzler der Kanzlerkandidat der Union
geäußert und er hat ein sehr sehr
spannenden Satz gesagt er hat nämlich
gesagt in den Medien würde geschrieben
ähm dass er ein regierungsanspruch dass
wir so formuliert als ein
regierungsanspruch formuliert haben er
sagt aber dass er nicht der Fall und er
verweist auf die Ergebnisse und ein
neues Parteiensystem also die engen
Ergebnisse würden zeigen dass es ein
neues Parteiensystem gibt aber das
bedeutet nicht gleichzeitig dass man
Ansprüche formuliere also man nimmt
etwas zurück von gestern Abend am Ende
zumindest das war die Wahrnehmung da hat
Armin Laschet gesagt wir erheben ein
regierungsanspruch jetzt sagt der nein
das sei nicht der Fall aber es gebe ein
neues Parteiensystem gleichzeitig hat
Armin Laschet in dieser Sitzung klar
gemacht dass er nicht
Fraktionsvorsitzender werden will dass
er die Gespräche aus der Situation des
Parteivorsitzenden führen will das
bedeutet am Ende Ralf Brinkhaus der
unionsfraktionschef kann drin bleiben
silvia breher hat sich dort ebenfalls
geäußert aus dem Präsidium sie hat auch
noch einmal kritisiert dass sozusagen
dieser Eindruck dass man jetzt den
Anspruch stellt nicht gut sein da läuft
jetzt eine hitzige Debatte gleichzeitig
scheint es so dass die Union geschlossen
ist dass man nicht auf den Vorsitzenden
losgeht sondern dass man taktisch wartet
was jetzt passiert in diesem Gesprächen
um Jamaika in diesem Krimi in diesem
Kampf in diesem Krieg um die beste für
Deutschland ja hochspannend wirklich aus
einem wir wollen es als so ein bisschen
Paul ein wir würden total gerne und
versuchen es weiter geworden
die CDU macht sich jetzt schon deutlich
kleiner als gestern so breitbeinig wie
man da gestern aufgetreten ist was wir
jetzt alle erstaunt hat steht man jetzt
heute da nicht mehr da genauso ist es
Kai und das ist das spannende also wie
will man jetzt in diese Gespräche
reingehen das bedeutet auch dass man am
Ende vielleicht erstmal will dass die
Ampel scheitern könnte bevor man in
Jamaika reingeht geworden
[Musik]